- So you and Nicole just
celebrated your 15th anniversary.
Congratulations.
That's amazing.
- Thank you.
- I feel like marriage can
be hard in general, but like,
especially under a microscope,
it can be really hard.
So that's really cool.
And I heard that she
recently said that initially
you weren't into her.
And I just, here's the question.
Who's not into Nicole Kidman?
- That's not true, that's not true.
That's why you gotta
have context for things.
- I was like, where was
your bar for humanity?
If Nicole Kidman didn't make the cut.
- It wasn't how high, it was
how low mine was about myself.
- No!
- Truly.
This is no, I don't mean that,
literally, I mean, I was like,
there's no way this girl
is interested in me at all.
So someone had given me her number.
I couldn't bring myself
to call that number.
I was so yeah.
- People just came up to you
and gave you Nicole Kidman's number?
- No, no, that's a whole different story.
- Okay, I was like, I want your life.
- Point of this story was it was more just
- [Kelly] You were nervous about it.
- I was nervous, yeah.
- Oh, okay.
So what, you also speaking
where you did a song
for "9 Perfect Strangers," right?
I love the show that she did.
- "Crimson Blue"
- Yeah, did she ask you to do that?
Or were you like into doing that?
- We wanted to write some
songs and Nick said, you know,
could you write some songs
maybe that would work in
"9 Perfect Strangers"?
And so a couple of friends of mine and I
wrote a whole bunch of songs
and they chose "Crimson Blue."
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, it was wild because
the director said, can you
I said, what's the directive of this?
What do you want?
What sort of song you want?
And he said kind of
trippy, Pink Floyd-ish,
with sort of Eastern
meditative, ethereal, go ahead.
I'm like, what?
I wrote I never saw the sky Crimson Blue
kaleidoscope my eyes, shapes and hues.
So we may as well been high writing that.
- I'm so into that.
I feel like I'm reading
"Alice in Wonderland."
I heard that she was in
character the whole time.
Like she said she was in character.
Was she in character
the whole time at home?
- No, not at home.
- 'Cause I'm like if you were coming home
to that every night,
it's amazing that you made it 15 years.
That's creepy.
- It's pretty sexy.
- Kinda creepy as well.
She kinda, I was like,
I can't tell if she's really
stage five creepy or like cool.
Or like she had me
guessing the whole time.
- You have creepy in stages.
I like this.
- [Kelly] I actually like creepy.
- Stage five creepy.
- [Kelly] I'm really into creepy.
- How many stages are there by the way?
- 11, Spinal Tap. (laughs)